six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number we're gonna go
to the 72 zero area code caller from
seven to zero who's been holding on for
a while tell us who you are and what's
on your mind today my name is Tom I'm
from Denver and my question is with all
the wrangling YouTube seem to do one of
you guys would you take an offer from
like MSNBC you're one of those people
somewhat how Hank did I don't know ten
years ago or so
absolutely the second they come calling
I'm out of here
no I'm kidding around listen the truth
is that they're not going to come and
make me any offers right my brand of
politics is not I'm outside of the
acceptable range of discussion for
basically for corporate media so they're
never really going to come to me every
once in a while I'm invited to do like a
guest appearance on CNN or something
like that I've actually never been on
MSNBC interesting with CNN and Fox News
Academy but not MSNBC but they're not
going to come and ask me for that and
you know I I like doing this show and I
want to grow this show as much as
possible and the editorial freedom that
I have here and the financial
independence that I have it's really
worth a lot and do I really want to go
work 80 hours a week or one of those
companies and have you know ten bosses
not really you know but the thing is
where it's not going to be a choice I
have to make because I can't imagine
they're gonna come calling anytime soon
I think the first class lights repealed
then on isn't that gonna kind of
strangle you guys even more so and
wouldn't that make you uh I wouldn't
take away even more than they've already
taken from me it would have that
potential but I'm hoping that we're sort
of gonna be under the radar enough to
not really be targeted in the ways that
maybe Netflix would be but yeah you're
bringing up a really good point okay
okay last question for you David I don't
Ahmed mugs on the website am I wrong
there you're not wrong basically I just
haven't yet found a manufacturer I have
like one mug on my desk
that's a single prototype and I think
it's also made in giant yeah I can't in
good in good faith cell made in china
cups but the made in USA coffee mugs
that i found are like 15 or 17 dollars
each and we need to make a little bit of
money on it and i don't think people are
really i buy a 20 or 25 dollar mug you
know yeah yeah okay okay well thanks for
taking my call David all right no
problem
I'm in Denver great to hear from you
much appreciate it hope to hear from you
again